I'm talking about plastic surgery let's
get into it I won't talk
I want to talk about it what the [__] is
going on man
what the [__] is going on
plastic surgery is that all-time high I
don't even know if you noticed but back
in the day plastic surgery was a secret
like nobody wanted anybody to know that
they were getting work done it was all
nose jobs and titty jobs nose titties
nose titties nose titties that's all it
was
back in the day people got mad at their
doctor you better not say [__] about
what happened here today
only two people that we knew that got
work done back in the day was Dolly
Parton and Michael Jackson that's a
[__] fact well the only two people
Mike showed up with that new nose we
knew that's not your nose Mike something
happened
that's not the same nose
today is different everybody's getting
work done men women
have taken it to a new level though the
new [__] that the women are doing is the
BBL
the BBL what the [__]
Jesus Christ
these [__] look like ants that's
right I said it
they look like ants
somebody's got to say it
Somebody's gotta say it
and if you don't believe me I challenge
you to go look at a picture of an ant
and tell me I'm [__] lying
big ass head Little Neck hard chest
skinny waist fat ass you ever see an ant
ass it's got ass you haven't seen in it
when I was an insect I [__] ain't
swear to God I'll do it
everybody wants change everybody's
looking for change a friend of mine's
got a huge forehead right one of the
worst foreheads I've ever seen in my
[__] life huge he told me the other
day he said Kev I'm thinking about
getting my forehead reduced this is what
he said to me
I couldn't believe what the [__] I heard
I said what the [__] you just say to me
he said I'm thinking about getting my
forehead reduced I already talked to my
doctor he said he can do it the average
forehead is four fingers wide
he said I got an 8 to 12 figure
situation
but he can flip it down he said he can
flip it down flip it down
that's not a hack what are you talking
about it's your [__] forehead [__]
what about your brain you said oh he can
push that back he gonna push that back
raise my eyes up so I can see better I
bet you [__] well
everybody wants change
LeBron James real good friend of mine
well he was he hasn't heard this joke
yet we'll see what happens
we'll see what happens
I remember in the beginning of LeBron
career he was going bald his hair was
real thin up top you could count the
hairs on top of his [__] hand
you know how I know that because I was
the one counting the hairs on top of his
[__] head one
two-ish
[Music]
I didn't see Brian for like three weeks
I didn't see him and I didn't talk to
him Brian showed up and when I was at he
had a head full of hair
walked in that [__] with all this
confidence like I didn't see him three
weeks ago with the [__] truth on his
goddamn head
he walked in he's like what up what up
what up what up what up what up what up
what's going on
I said what the [__] is going on with
you
the [__] is out of your goddamn head you
start kicking me chill can't chill I
said get your [__] feet off of me
ain't no chill I wanna know what the
[__] that is on Brian Head
I'll tell you what it's not I knew what
it was it I knew it wasn't a goddamn
toupee I knew that much you know how I
knew it wasn't the two pay because they
don't make two pains they never have
they never had
the [__] is that on your head LeBron Is
it alive is it alive
snatch it off right now
I wanted to
he's tall I can't get no way I'm getting
that but you get what I'm saying
[Music]